[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn and their job recruitment
platform which offers a smarter system
for the hiring process
if you've ever hired anyone or attempted
to do it you know that finding the right
people can be extremely difficult and if
you don't have a direct referral from
someone you trust you're left to use job
boards that don't really offer any
real-world networking approach and what
I mean by that is in contrast LinkedIn
which is the world's largest
professional network has a built in
ecosystem that allows you to not only
search for employees but also interact
with them and their connections and
their former employers or colleagues in
a way that closely mimics real-life
communication more than 70% of the
workforce in the u.s. uses LinkedIn and
more than 22 million professionals view
and apply to LinkedIn every single week
unlike generic job boards LinkedIn
considers skills experience and location
to match you with candidates making it
easier to find quality candidates and
maybe above all you can directly contact
a candidate's connections to get a good
sense of if they are a good fit for your
business
so visit linkedin.com forward slash Tim
and receive a $50 credit towards your
first job post that's linkedin.com
forward slash tim TI m for $50 off
this episode is brought to you by red
dahlias new book principles if you're a
frequent listener of this podcast you
might recall that Rey was a guest on the
show his episode was extremely popular
and in that episode he shared his
thoughts and everything from how he
makes investment decisions to
cryptocurrency and beyond his story Ray
Dalio you should look him up for sure is
fascinating he started his investment
company some people would call it a
hedge fund there are different names
Bridgewater associates out of a
two-bedroom apartment at age 26 now it
has roughly 160 billion dollars in
assets under management over 42 years
he's built Bridgewater into what Fortune
considers the fifth most important
private company in the u.s. along the
way Dalio took tons and tons of notes on
what worked what didn't work and it was
refined over time for training purposes
with his employees managers and so on
Dalio became one of the 100 most
influential people in the world
according to time and one of the 100
wealthiest people in the world according
to Forbes in this book principles which
has a permanent spot on my bookshelf
also has blurbs and testimonials from
people like Bill Gates Michael Bloomberg
and many many more ray shares in those
pages the unconventional principles that
he's developed or find and used over the
past 40 years to create unique results
in both life business certainly in
investing and at which any person
organization can adopt to help further
their goals these principles are what he
believes is the reason behind his many
many successes and principles the book
also offers a clear very straightforward
approach to decision making the dahlia
believes anyone can apply both in life
and work I highly highly recommend it it
will help you to be calm in almost any
context a clearer thinker so visit
principals dot-com for more details
amazing that he actually has that URL to
visit principals comm for more details
and to pick up a copy check it out
[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show more specifically
another edition of the Tim Ferriss Radio
Hour where I go back through the 300
plus guests who have been on this show
think about the conversations and look
for patterns or themes that we can
explore and this episode will dig into
travel one of my favorite topics and I
will take partial credit or blame in
advance as it might make you want to
quit your job and head off to the
airport with a backpack coincidentally
exactly what I am doing tomorrow and why
I'm recording this intro way way past
midnight
now I've interviewed some fascinating
people from around the world it's kind
of crazy to think this is my job how
happy am i how lucky am i and in the
next hour we will actually travel around
the world with them in a way because we
recorded these episodes all over the
planet we'll also explore specific tips
and strategies from our conversations
related to how they think about travel
how they personally travel the tools and
gadgets they use and the role that
travel might play in your life first I
talk to the one and only Ralf Potts the
author of vagabonding one of my favorite
books of all time some of you may know
starting around 2004 I traveled the
world for roughly 18 months after this
complete implosion and deciding to
either shut my business down or
completely reinvent it and extricate
myself the lessons learned over those 18
months form the basis for much of my
first book the 4-hour workweek on that
journey which ranged from the back
alleys of Berlin to lakes in Patagonia I
had next to nothing one suitcase one
backpack and only two books one of those
books was Walden by Henry David Thoreau
naturally and the other was vagabonding
subtitle and uncommon guide to the art
of long-term world travel written by
Ralph Potts which is about a lot more
than just travel people you know they
put off what they really want to do
until they're too old to actually do it
next my friend Kevin Rose and I share
our travel experiences while sitting on
tatami mats in a traditional Inn in the
Japanese hillside in Kanazawa
specifically and we cover everything
from how to cope when not speaking the
local language to how Kevin has to hide
his tattoos those tattoos in certain
countries including Japan went into use
a spa and she goes tattoos and I said
yes and she handed me flesh colored tape
then I talked travel and diving
adventures among other things with Phil
Keoghan from The Amazing Race and I just
wrote down everything that I felt like I
had all the time in the world to do to
get out to go okay this is not a dress
rehearsal you can die you will die you
don't know how long you've got before
you die
and of course the incredible Kevin Kelly
and I get into our favorite travel tools
and gadgets what else do you have in
your backpack which is stuffed here in
the back of our car right now so let's
jump right in
Ralph Potts at Ralph's pots on twitter
has reported from more than 60 countries
for the likes of National Geographic
Traveler The New Yorker slate.com
outside the New York Times Magazine the
believer it goes on and on and Sports
Illustrated National Public Radio you
name it his adventures have taken him
across six continents and include
piloting a fishing boat 900 miles down
the lotion or lotion Mekong
hitchhiking across Eastern Europe
traversing Israel on foot bicycling
across Burma driving a Land Rover across
South America sounds like a long long
ass trip and traveling around the world
for six weeks with no luggage or bags of
any kind
Ralph is perhaps best known for
promoting the ethic of independent
travel and his book on the subject of
vagabonding which I mentioned before
subtitle an uncommon guide to the art of
long term world travel has been through
28 printings and translated into many
languages it is also by the way the
reason I started the Tim Ferriss book
club and produce an audio book of this
book because it could not be found and
that bothered me when you can find out
all about that at audible.com four words
on Tim's books if you want to see the
other books in that selection but back
to Ralph he won the 2009 Lowell Tom
award from the Society of American
travel writers and became the first
American author to win Italy's
prestigious coveted chatlin prize for
travel writing many people fantasize
about travel yet they never follow
through they never booked their trip and
take those first steps Roth explains in
what follows the concept of vagabonding
and how it differs from just another
vacation well I like that you bring up
the idea of fantasizing about travel
because I think it's something that
everybody does and it's one of those top
three if not top two or one things that
people dream about that and you see it
in the movies all the time and in fact I
mentioned this in Baga bonding you know
the heist movie where the whole goal is
to have this complicated robbery so they
can have enough money to move overseas
to a wonderful place and as I say in the
book is you don't need a rob a bank to
do that in fact you can do that for a
cost that is equal to and sometimes less
than your cost of living in a major
American city and so I think an
important principle I bring up in
vagabonding is saying don't don't put
this off if you're dreaming about travel
and most people do and you know and if
you don't dream about travel that's fine
but I really address these travel dreams
which are so common that don't wait
until you tell you're too old because
you know retirement isn't necessarily
the best time to to do something like
this and in fact Henry David Thoreau I
think Walden was the other book you took
on your travels that's right talks about
how people and I'm not quoting him
directly they you know they put off what
they really want to do until they're too
old to actually do it you know that's a
paraphrase and so if you are 18 28 you
know 38 48 whenever you're dreaming
about travel put make your goals soon
and and don't put off those goals
because they're very attainable and you
know I think there's a lot of fears that
are tied in to confronting vagabonding
which you asked me if the for the
definition it's not wanting as long-term
travel it's not just a vacation it's not
a week or two off that you know society
gives you as a vacation it's
six months or two years or you know six
weeks but you make for yourself to
travel in earnest not as a consumer
experience not as a vacation but as you
know a more deeply meaningful life
experience and as a way to actualize
your wealth of time and I think this is
an idea we'll come back to a lot and
it's something that you write about as
well as me is the idea of tying wealth
the idea that your experiences are more
valuable in life than the things that
you accumulate and the things that are
always being touted as the most
important things in life so travel is a
great way to cash in on your time wealth
and vagabonding just by definition is a
more meaningful way of travel it's a way
of slowing down and really discovering
parts of yourself instead of just buying
a lot of experiences which is which
we've sort of been conditioned to do as
American consumers my first vagabonding
trip was 20 years ago this year oddly
enough and happy anniversary thank you
thank you it was just this time that I
was that I was straggling back to Kansas
after having this amazing eight-month
trip around North America and it was a
trip that I thought would be my last I
thought I would get to travel out of my
system so I could become a responsible
American workaholic and then maybe
return to travel when I was old but you
mentioned the idea of fear and the fears
I had going out were you know is this
gonna be expensive it's gonna is this
gonna be dangerous am I gonna come back
and be compromised professionally and
all of those sort of turned into the
into the opposite that it was a lot
safer than I expected it was a lot
cheaper than I expected and I came back
and for 20 years I've been integrating
travel with with a professional life
that continues to diversify I continue
to to to do other things to make money
well at the same time having big swathes
of time to travel and I'm not suggesting
that everybody needs to you know become
a vagabond or for a 20 year chunk and in
some ways I travel a lot less than I
used to you know 10 or 15 years ago but
it's something that you can do it's an
option that you can have and it's it's
not an an option that you wait for life
to give you you create it
and so I'm a big believer in the active
aspect of vagabonding of saving your
money but the lottery is another
metaphor I use a lot in Baga bonding
that people keep waiting for the lottery
to reward them but as we all know the
odds that you're gonna win the lottery
is pretty low but you've already won the
lottery we're born with time wealth and
so it's just a matter of creating these
travel experiences or these time rich
experiences through things like
simplicity and just the decision to make
these sort of things happen what type of
sites or resources would you recommend
to people who are trying to find
comparable folks let's just say people
who will help them alleviate their fear
of travel or just in general what type
of online resources do you recommend
well Google for one I mean if you just
Google you know thirty five-year-old
years old two kids one year of travel
then odds are you'll find twenty blogs
of people in that demographic who are
doing just that so so really be be
unabashed and very specific about
googling you know your fears or your
demographic and just see who like you is
is out traveling the world there's a lot
of great traveler communities I've been
affiliated with boots and allcom since
the very beginning of vagabonding and
part of their mo is just sort of
creating community and and and support
for people and they have they have blogs
and resources on their site and there's
other travel communities as well it's
boots the letter N all calm right yeah
Bo o TS n al calm and they've been
operating out of Portland Oregon for
years and have just quietly been doing
very the nice work of reassurance and
saying oh so you so you're worried about
it and around the world flight well
here's what around the around the world
flights look you know you're worried
about a certain situation you know
here's here are some resources for that
and and they're not alone I'm most
familiar with them because we've we've
been we've sort of shared a similar
mission for a long time but
there are big communities of travelers
who are happy to help and and sort of
help newbies feel better about these
prospects of long-term travel for you
and and perhaps there are older examples
but you mentioned that your UT your
taking a trip before we started
recording and you're doing a home swap
is that is a would you mind perhaps
elaborating on how some of those options
work those that you're familiar with
because I think that many people who
consider travel think in terms of one of
their main expenses being staying in a
hotel right and I'd love for you to to
share any of your thoughts on that
yeah well it's shifted the way the
travel world works in in in some ways
that are delightfully convenient and in
some ways that are a little bit strange
I think that technology is one of these
double-edged swords that in some ways
has turn us into insufferable micro
managers on the road can you elaborate
on that yeah well I'll start with the
negative okay you know I I the travel
culture which I started in which was 20
years ago but really my more
international traveler travels are more
like 15 years ago it's about showing up
in town and knowing that when you get
there
the unexpected awaits you that you that
you're going to walk to the hotel
district you may have a guidebook with
some hotel recommendations but you're
gonna shop for your hotel you're not
gonna find a deal online you're gonna
walk in there you're gonna see the room
you're gonna haggle because in in in all
throughout Asia you know basically any
place outside of the industrial world
prices are up for grabs and and haggling
in person is so much more gives you so
much more leverage than haggling online
because you can go in look at the room
and physically leave if the owner
doesn't give you a price that you're
that you're into and so these days it
has become so convenient not always a
bad thing but it has become so
convenient that people just assume that
the best deals to be had are the ones
online and then pretty soon you've
locked in you're traveling for six weeks
and you know where you're sleeping every
night in a
and it really compromises the
flexibility of travel and and the
serendipity of being inspired by a place
and thinking I'm gonna stay here for a
few days or Wow I just met this traveler
who told me about this great place up in
the mountains and I'm not gonna go to
Varanasi I'm gonna go up into the
Himalayas and spend my time there
this technologically enhanced
micromanaging cuts into that serendipity
in a certain way and it also connects us
to a home and and again it's a two-edged
thing social media and the constant
connectivity that comes with smart
phones for example allows us to really
find things that we couldn't find before
but it cuts into the idea of wandering
around and finding things by surprise
finding things organically and letting
letting a destination reveal itself to
us on its own terms instead of sort of
finding that place as a consumer before
we get there and a lot of technologies
have eliminated things like loneliness
and boredom which sounds good and is
good to a certain extent but loneliness
and boredom can lead you to those
moments that that sort of force you into
a new version of yourself they force you
to be more extroverted a totally totally
agreed they force you to read the local
newspaper instead of you know looking
through your facebook feed right and so
that's that is what we're up against
with this technological these
technological advances and I don't want
to be the grumpy older traveler because
I remember being being 20 and listening
to these you know baby boom era hippies
sort of lectured me on how travel used
to be you know back at a time when
telephone answering machines and credit
cards were seen as this decadent form of
Technology and and so I know that there
are younger travelers who don't know
anything but the constant connectivity
of travel but unplugging is important
and we can talk more about that if you
want and we can also talk about the
pluses and they're I have many recent
examples about how technology have have
helped this recent home exchange is just
a longtime friend who lives in Brooklyn
she's a writer and she wants a quiet
place I have 30 acres in Kansas and so I
get an awesome pad in Brooklyn for a
week and she gets a quiet farm in Kansas
for a time I think in places
more expensive places like Europe you
know the hostel was your go-to it was
worth if you wanted to save money you
would go to the to the youth hostel and
it was a great place to meet people you
get a cheap bed you went you you would
forego a few amenities but you would
hang out in the hostel well I went to
Amsterdam this summer I teach I teach a
writing course in Paris every summer and
my sister and my nephew came and visited
me and we wanted to go see Amsterdam and
using Airbnb I was able to get a full
cottage a 15 minute train ride outside
of central Amsterdam for about half the
price as a hostel for three people in
the center of Amsterdam so instead of
staying at somewhat grungy hostel in the
red-light district we were staying in
this little town filled with windmills
and we had our own house to ourselves
and we could just walk down the street
and get groceries and so there that was
an Airbnb hookup couchsurfing is a
similar has similar benefits it just
allows you to break out of not only that
old hotel set of assumptions but also
out of the hostel set of assumptions the
idea that the cheapest option in any
place is going to be a hostel especially
traveling in groups for the three of us
if I'd been alone maybe I maybe the the
cottage wouldn't have been as cheap as
the hostel but with three of us where
you're getting hostel one bed at a time
we just got the perfect place to stay
through Airbnb and so those services and
even social media even going on Facebook
or Twitter and and I'm not a big
believer of tweeting while you travel I
think that that really puts you into
this home mindset and it pulls you out
of the place where you are and the point
of travel is experiencing what's before
your eyes and not what's coming across
your social media feed but before your
travel before one's travels I'm a big
fan of throwing throwing out a tweet or
Facebook post that says hey look I'm
gonna be in this place what are some
suggestions and that is something that
didn't exist ten years ago and is not
tied to a business or social networking
thing like Airbnb or in couchsurfing but
it could just be that your buddy from
high school has a friend who's in the
military
in Germany and they have an
ex-girlfriend who lives in Stockholm and
suddenly you have a place to stay
through very random circumstances and so
that kind of it's it's the old model of
sitting in the hostel or sitting in a
guest house or a bar in an exotic part
of the world talking to the six
travelers who are there with you and
then giving you advice on points further
down the road that principle has been
taken to social media and through
networking that's another way that
technology has allowed that that that
old hostel room is actually killed at
the literal hospital room where people
are now staring at their phones in the
hostel room but it is it has expanded
the virtual hostel room we're instead of
talking to the six travelers you're with
physically you can be talking to 600
travelers through your networks who
might have some good advice for you this
next segment was recorded in rural Japan
late one evening with my friend Kevin
Rose at Kevin Rose on Twitter
affectionately known as keV keV by those
in the know
serial entrepreneur world-class investor
and all-around wild and crazy guy we've
been through a lot together and here we
discussed Japan how to do it cheaply and
many other things and the tips in this
next segment apply to just about
anywhere not just the Land of the Rising
Sun and we are at ah da as the name of
the place and if you hear any waterfall
like sounds in the background that is
because we have natural onsen bringing
water into the rooms where there are
wooden tubs that are effectively
indoor/outdoor there's an open wall so
you look out into a forest slash
hillside and the steam pours out into
the great outdoors it is winter so
there's tons of fog and mist and so on
it's just a magical place yeah it's
absolutely beautiful and one of the
reasons why I chose this place to stay
is one I had never stayed in a ryokan
like traditional Japanese house before
and I always wanted to do that and
number two when you're talking about
ions and like a natural spring it's very
difficult because in Japan if you have
any tattoos whatsoever you are forbidden
from doing
beyond zen-like you can't go up in
Bath's public baths because they say
that you're a Yakuza
yeah it's associated with organized
crime so if you have tattoos as kevin
does yes my little pony on both deltoids
they're beautiful long-haired the
tassels it's a quite a breathtaking
thing it is breathtaking and you are not
allowed to go to public baths or most of
them also true in say hotels where they
have beachfront you're not allowed to go
on the beach if you have yes also hotels
when you're going to just use their kind
of spa because I went in there one time
I was staying at I think was a pencil
and went in to use a spa and she goes
tattoos and I said yes and she handed me
flesh colored tape like a little square
of tape and and I have a few and so I
was like I'm gonna need the whole roll
and I'm not being I didn't actually
happen I didn't go in so I've been
kicked out but this is nice it's in a
room so every single room here has its
own little private bath hot water being
piped in and it's it's been very
relaxing and I should say also we're not
gonna talk about Japan the whole time
but I do think Japan is worth
highlighting for a few reasons I mean I
was an exchange student here at age 15
which was really my first time abroad
and that year completely changed my life
I lived with host families I went to a
Japanese school I was the only American
in my class photo which is very easy
Where's Waldo all in school uniforms
selling crew-cut Whitehead and that all
Japanese kids about 5,000 and it has
proven to be such a subtle and nuanced
culture simultaneously you can come here
someone who doesn't speak Japanese get
completely lost be completely bewildered
the English level is generally pretty
low here so it can be a totally alien
environment you can't read any signs and
it's not dangerous right and the people
will go above and beyond to try and
kind of decipher what you're saying with
your hands well not only that so why
don't you tell the story of Tony and the
earphones
well yet what are your phones the
earphones that he dropped on the sole oh
yeah yeah so two days ago well there was
two stories okay so this is classic
Tokyo for you and it's part of the
reason why I love Japan so much it's
like the people here are just so
friendly and really concerned with your
well-being
so Tony one of the the members that was
traveling with us that is traveling with
us
he dropped his his headphones and just
you know we're talking standard kind of
Apple headphones you know white cord
whatever and we walked into a coffee
shop and now just for context this is
only one of the busiest streets in a
shopping district yes in Tokyo yeah so
those people will just you know Avenue
in New York City yeah just like all over
the place just you know probably
stepping on the headphones and whatnot
somebody on the second floor of a
building across the street was looking
out the window saw that these these
these small white headphones fell out of
his pocket ran down the stairs grabbed
the headphones figured out which coffee
bar we had gone into and then proceeded
to enter in and hand back the headphones
which was just nuts and then on top of
that the exact same coffee bar I had
gotten out of a taxi left my cell phone
in the taxi and you know of course when
you're in the States you're like [ __ ]
like my cell phone's gone I'm never
gonna see it again and so I used Find My
Phone you know the Apple built-in
feature so you can see where they your
phone is I used it off of my wife's cell
phone and you know it's 2025 minutes
away from where we're at in a taxi and
I'm like aha dammit like how am I ever
gonna get this back and I press the
button to which sends a signal to the
cell phone so it sends out an audible
alert to the you know so anyone who ever
is is nearby can hear that all of a
sudden I'm watching on GPS the phone
starts getting closer and closer and
closer
this driver drives all the way back 20
plus minutes comes up the stairs to the
coffee shop where you
were I had left him and then hands me my
phone back
I tried to tip him you know I'm thinking
like in the states you know you give
somebody 20 40 50 bucks I thank you so
much he wouldn't accept my tip and was
just so ply bowed to me and left he's
like yeah man it just makes you when you
live when you live in the states you're
just like what what happens like with a
few friends with us and it also makes
you feel like a in many many many
instances and uncivilized Harry Savage
let you wake up feeling you know you're
gonna be ashamed of at least simple
things you do that day that's right but
it's it's a wonderful environment and
one thing that I want to underscore
before we move on I'm sure we'll come
back to it is that you don't have to
have a lot of money or spend a lot of
money to enjoy Tokyo this is a common
misconception it can be extremely
expensive but it doesn't have to be
extremely expensive and certainly Japan
as a whole doesn't need to be extremely
expensive when I was here 15 I had no
money whatsoever and you can for
instance find stores you would recognize
like 7-eleven that are completely
different from the equivalent at home
and you can go into a 7-eleven for
instance and you can grab one of my
favorite on-the-go bytes which is
onigiri
these are rice balls wrapped and dry
seaweed and filled with various meats
vegetables or fish say to know whatever
it might be and those typically cost
about 110 yen so let's just call that a
dollar and you can find those at
7-eleven a store called Sun cus s UNK us
or Lawson it's packaged in such a way
that you pull apart the plastic which
keeps the seaweeds separate it
automatically wraps this rice triangle
and you have effectively an entire meal
right there for somewhere between one
and two dollars yeah it's well you know
it's funny I don't know if I told you
this but I was out here with David Chang
I'm sure lot people are familiar with
him but he's one of the probably the top
five chefs in the United States very
famous Momofuku COO yeah just like bar
right yeah milk bar and we happen to be
here on the same trip with some friends
and he was ranting and
raving about the 7-eleven egg salad
sandwich and this is like you know a
multi like you know is a I think it's
three Michelin stars at one of his
restaurant I'm top of the world chef
freaking out about a seven eleven
different 7-eleven in the United States
yeah I mean not high in food by any
means I mean a couple bucks for this egg
salad sandwich but prepared with like my
beer says prepared with pride yeah
there's so much a couple of other go
twos I'd suggest in Tokyo if you can get
a ticket go to the Ghibli Museum GHI bli
Museum which is the Museum it's think of
it as the Disney Museum for the Walt
Disney of Japan and that's miyazaki
hayao he did spirited away my favorite
movie my neighbor totoro a whole long
list of blockbuster and kind of genre
defining anime films and it is it is one
of the most incredible museums I've ever
been to it's in the middle of what they
call me taka forest which is right next
to her is you know cuz she's not Cohen
and then a lot a lot of things in Japan
are also free you can go to Harajuku har
AJ UK you where you can find on the
weekends Elvis impersonators doing their
dancing this has been going on for
decades now and you can also go to tuk
ish stability which is I guess Takeshita
Street or alleyway where you find dozens
or hundreds of teenagers and high
schoolers doing cosplay so they were
these crazy outfits and walk up and down
the streets or showing off the weirdest
outfits imagine into that a lot of
people are into it like do you are you
kind of like when you see a cosplay you
because it's like a sexual thing well
for so you know I think that for some
people that might be part of it but it I
think that it's just a form of hyper
expression in a culture where a lot of
people feel very repressed or overly
polite most of the time yeah and so then
they blow it out on the weekends and
they like put in pink contacts and white
hair and 12 inch platform shoes and
we're the wackiest should imagine a bowl
yeah maybe Walter in the in the States
cosplay is like a bigger because they
dress up like video game characters yeah
things like that when
you know Comic Con and whatnot oh yeah
well there are a lot of things that are
that's not really Japanese cosplay
though there are a lot of things that
are regular in other countries that end
up being adopted by weird niche groups
in the US and take on in some cases like
creepy or weird or elements right tango
in Argentina normal tango in some places
in the United States super weird
yeah and I'm just saying that as someone
who loves tango and dances and dances in
many places but primarily in Argentina
way back in the day
same thing with Japanese stuff it's like
Oh manga cool and then you find like a
little subculture in a given city in the
US and you're like wait a second it's
all 40 year old guys or we're like
reading creepy half porno a hentai manga
okay I don't think I'm gonna hang out
here right anymore so segue yes how do
we say away from that let's say wait
fall from hint by hint that you can look
up those people interested they're there
two books that have helped me review and
prep for this trip in terms of Japanese
that I'd like to suggest people check
out if you're interested in Japanese
very short and I was able to get through
these really quickly the first is
probably for people who speak more
intermediate Japanese so you'd want some
basics first
but it is 13 secrets for speaking fluent
Japanese and this is by I think it's
guiles or Giles GI le s let's say giles
marie mu r ra y so 13 secrets for
speaking fluent Japanese very very
helpful and then the second is maybe a
bit dry for some people but I like very
concise grammar summaries that are a
quick reference and this is Japanese
verbs and essentials of grammar and that
is by Rita Lampkin l am PK I am Phil
Keoghan Keo gh aan at Phil Keoghan on
Twitter has worked in television for
almost 30 years on more than a thousand
program episodes in more than a hundred
countries his work has earned him
numerous awards including ten that's
right 10 Primetime Emmys he is perhaps
best known as the co-executive producer
and host of CBS's series The Amazing
Race
but there's much
more to fill story including
unbelievable bucket lists near-death
experiences and all sorts of other
adventures and misadventures I was doing
a story about a 22 thousand ton
shipwreck that had sunken in New Zealand
and it was down about a hundred and
twenty feet underwater and it was on its
starboard side twenty-two thousand tons
is like it's as big as you know a cruise
liner that you see going around at the
ports around the world and big really
big and 120 feet is the for people
who've never done any scuba diving
unless you have special equipment I mean
that's not a lot of bottom time exactly
so most recreational divers get
certified to dive to about sixty feet
the best stuff that you see underwater
is generally in the first 30 feet
because once you get past 30 feet the
color changes you you lose all the reds
and everything becomes very blue so I
always say to people look you don't need
to go deep unless you're going on to a
wreck or something some real reason to
go deep
the only reason to go deep is you know
if it is a wreck you can get great
diving in 10 15 feet of water with the
coral close to the surface the colors
are brighter and so on but this wreck
was deep and and and as you said the
deeper you are the faster you chew
through air and you eat up air and that
affects how long you can stay down and
the longer you're down deep the more
nitrogen you get in your blood and so
it's it there's a real science to diving
and you have to be super careful as
you're a diver I am yeah so you
understand people get a nitrogen
narcosis yeah at exactly hundred twenty
feet I saw a guy start to try he tried
to take off all of his gear and just
drop it bring in a small group and he
was stopped but that was the guys that
worked at Chippendales I know they but
people yeah I've seen the same thing to
take the regulator out and they start
having conversations with fish yeah it's
not a good idea no it's getting narked
yeah yeah so that's all the more reason
to get properly certified so I was with
some very experienced divers and way
more experienced than me and they were
they were doing this salvage and we were
gonna be the
first people to shoot on the ship get to
go inside the ship and explore it and
the the cameramen that I was with is
also very experienced but because there
was because there's so much silt inside
the boat and there was a current as well
rolling through the boat we were we and
we in those days we were shooting on
film it's not like today well you could
go down with a great GoPro and some
lights and you know you could film for a
couple of hours we had a two and a half
minute roll of film in a 100-foot
daylight spool roll that was in a little
housing inside the kit so literally
that's the only amount of footage we had
to shoot on film that's how long I go
back so that the plan was that we would
go into the ballroom of the of the ship
and big big ballroom
and then the crew would come in from
another door and we would meet in the
middle so that we didn't stir up all the
silt going into the same entrances we'd
swim towards each other that get us
coming towards them and so we go down
and what I know now is if you go into a
wreck you tie a line on the outside of
the wreck so that you have something to
follow out if something goes wrong these
guys were so familiar with the wreck and
so experienced and knew the place so
well they didn't tie a line on and I
just sort of followed them in not
knowing that that was sort of what you
should do and you know the other rule
with diving is you never leave your dive
buddy so I'm following this guy and I
was too scared to tell him because I was
trying to be a man that before that I
was really claustrophobic so I go in
this little doorway and it would have
been like let's imagine a small window
like two by three we go through this
little porthole and then we start
weaving our way through the ship and I
as we going deeper and deeper and deeper
into the shipwreck I'm completely
disoriented it I have no idea where I am
I come my hand sweats just listening to
the description oh yeah and I started to
breathe like breathe but every time I
sort of like was at the point of tapping
him to go you know I got to get out of
here I feel panicky he just kept
disappearing deeper and deeper and
deeper in another corner in another
corner I thought and he was moving
quickly because he's
used to being in this wreck they're
doing the salvage on this thing so
finally we we come into an opening and
then he shines the light around and
there's this huge bull room now the ship
is on its starboard side on his right
side so all the tables on a ship roll
Baltic to the floor so imagine the
tables on a right angle to us and then
he gestures to me to hold on to the
table and then he told me on the surface
that he we were gonna switch out the
lights to save battery power because
it's cold and now we don't have a lot of
we've got seven mill wetsuits on is
pretty cold and you can feel kind of the
current pushing through the ship and
that's why we were holding on to the
table so we didn't drift in you know
through the room and now we're looking
ahead and he sort of points at me and
looks ahead and says that's where the
crew is going to come out and I knew
that that's where they're gonna come out
so I was like okay so we're waiting with
the lights off in the dark and I'm
processing a little of this and starting
to try to slow my breathing down and
like stay calm it's okay you know you're
with an expert everything is good and
after what seemed like like minutes well
I wanted to turn my light on but I also
didn't want to do it cuz I thought he'll
think I'm a wimp like why am i turning
well I just wanted to turn my light on
to see where I was like to have sent
some sense of where I was he flicks his
light on like in Halloween when you take
your life and put it at the chin and you
make yourself look scary right that's
all I remember the light went on it's
he's pointing from his chin looking up
he looks scary then he gestures me with
his hand puts it out in front of me like
wait then he points at my hands on the
table like and gestures for me to hold
onto the table and then boom he just
disappears around a corner and I had
don't have my light on he's got his
light on it and the light disappears and
he's gone well in that moment I'm like
why is he leaving why did he just leave
so in my haste to find my light - I've
start flailing around let go of the
table and I feel myself drifting away
from where the table is and moving
drifting into the ballroom and I just
went into a mad panic and I couldn't
find my light by the time I found my
life I'd silted up all the water
I couldn't see anything and now I don't
know where the table was that I was
meant to hold on to and I'm looking
ahead I can't see any lights I can't see
him and I started to breathe really
really fast and now you're a diver you
understand this but when you dive and
for anybody who's never had a regulator
in their mouth if you breathe too
quickly there's a little diaphragm that
allows for exhalation and inhalation in
the in the regulator that you put in
your mouth to suck in air if you go too
fast the diaphragm can't keep up with
the speed of inhalation and exhalation
and then you start to suck water and
then so I started like taking a little
bits of water and I'm beating the the
valve and just panicking like mad mad
panic and I thought I have to get out of
here and well you all you want to do is
just get out right but I don't know how
to get out I don't know where
up-and-down is I don't the bubbles don't
go up when the ships on his side like
that and you deep down they hit the
walls and then they run up the walls
they they follow we had pass and I
thought I have no idea where I am right
now I can't even see where the table is
and panicking panicking and I knew that
someone had died in there someone had
gone in there and got disconnected from
a group and he had died and drifted off
into the ship and died I also knew that
one of the engineers never made it out
when the ship sank in the first place so
I and just to set the stage also for
people listening I remember when I did a
dive at the Blue Hole in Belize which is
about a hundred 20 feet this is when
this guy got narked it takes so long to
get down because you're equalizing yeah
by the time you get down at least we
were told at the time with the gear we
had you have eight minutes yeah so all
of this is happening yeah very quickly
very quickly very quickly and we we
weren't on nitrox night rocks as you
know is a is a is a mixed gas that you
can get where it has more oxygen and
less nitrogen so it increases your
bottom time so this is pre nitrox days
and so yes you're absolutely right we
had a very limited window which is why
he must have gone off to find the crew
because he realized we were eating up a
lot of time and where were they we're
with a crew well I don't remember
exactly how I got from there to the boat
but this guy obviously came back to get
me
and really it's all a blur between
panicking mad panic eyes like wide like
saucers to being on the boat to looking
up into the sky and seeing the most
amazing blue I'd ever seen in my life
like just look like totally surreal and
then and and I'm lying on the ground
like breathing and I look up and all
these faces looking down at Phil you
good you're good and I'm like yeah yeah
I'm good I'm good like trying to play
like nothing happened but my heart is
pounding like pounding and I was so like
the feeling the feeling of euphoria the
the relief of being alive to know that I
was alive was was like nothing I'd ever
experienced and it really was all this
stuff It was as if my IQ went up 25
points in that moment you know what I
mean because I was like how dumb will
you that I thought you were going to
live forever how dumb were you that you
did you've been doing all these dumb
things in your life and you have real
really of no purpose in life and I
started to think about this is all
happening while I'm having these
conversations but I'm like I'm thinking
man I I love girls and I haven't even
like really explored that whole world I
don't want to say it was the first thing
because I don't want you to get the
wrong idea about me but it was up there
and I was like damn you know you got a
lot to do with your life so no but there
were all these things that came to me
and a lot of them were very selfish I
was 19 years old so I got myself
together and I I wanted to find a piece
of paper and a pen and I just wrote down
just everything that I felt like I had
all the time in the world to do and that
I had to get down on a piece of paper to
get out to go okay this is not a dress
rehearsal you can die you will die you
don't know how long you've got before
you
I you better figure out what you're
doing with your life and you better get
on with it straight away and one of the
first things on my list was go back in
the shipwreck seriously because I
thought I cannot walk away from this
fear I was so petrified of what had
happened and I and I decided I would
explain to the diver you know that I
found it challenging he knew that but I
said it's like kind of like falling off
a horse I really felt like gotta get
back on gotta get back on I have to go
back because if I let this fear get on
with some string or so well I didn't
actually go back with shame because I
didn't even I didn't I didn't have time
to do the lesson about this string yeah
but I but I went back with by disclosing
a little more of my fear to the other
diver and who's more honest and and then
he when he knew that and we had to get
this thing shot he was obviously more
aware of you know he thought I was so
because I was so gung-ho like he didn't
have any indication that there was any
fear in me at all but then I kind of
said you know listen to me and I really
freaked out he goes oh no kidding
and I and I said but I need to go back
we've got to go back and do this and we
went back and we did it and we shot it
and that was the start that was the
first thing I picked off my list
question for you so when you decided to
go back down yeah as your descendant
petrified and getting ready to go
through that tiny opening yeah what was
the self-talk I mean it's a long time
ago but what what is your self-talk like
in a moment like that well it's
something that I've used a lot since
then which was instead of internalizing
everything I looked out and what I
realized was that this guy was super
experienced and had been down on that
shipwreck many times and come out of
there successfully many times and if I
followed his procedure and if I observed
him being an expert doing something and
looked out at that rather than turning
it back into my own head about what I
didn't know and what I couldn't do that
I was in good hands so ever since that
moment and all the crazy things that
I've done
I've taken a tremendous amount of
comfort in being surrounded by people
who I know are better at me at doing
something who have tremendous expertise
at whatever they're doing and to really
observe them in that moment when they
are in there when they are using
expertise than there are they have take
that is taken possibly at least 10,000
hours to get to and and to look at it in
a way like wow how cool is that I'm with
this person man or woman whoever it is
that is allowing me and giving me the
privilege to be with them to do what
they do so well and they are specialists
and they're so good and so you would be
explicitly reminding yourself of all
these things if you're going into a
situation that is provoking nerves and
fear is that yeah the voice inside the
head it is it's I made up a quote which
I really that I share with a lot of
people which is focus on what you do
have and what you can do instead of what
you don't have and what you can't do up
next Kevin Kelley at Kevin to Kelley the
number two at Kevin to Kelley on Twitter
might just be the real life most
interesting man in the world
he would be my vote I think maybe tied
with another Jen who's gonna come up in
a second Kevin is senior maverick at
Wired magazine which he co-founded in
1993 he also co-founded the all species
foundation a non-profit aimed at
cataloging and identifying every living
species on earth in his spare time he
writes best-selling books many of them
like the inevitable subtitle
understanding the 12 technological
forces that will shape our future and by
the way he's considered an incredibly
accurate futurist his predictions of pan
out over and over again even though he
spends part of the year with the Amish
but that's another story he co-founded
the Rosetta project which is building an
archive of all documented human language
and serves on the board of the long now
foundation he alongside Stuart brand and
others Stuart brand might be the person
tied with Kevin for the most interesting
man in the world
nomination he alongside Stuart brand and
others is also investigating how to
revive and restore endangered or
species including the woolly mammoth yep
Jurassic Park stuff but in real life I'd
always wanted to travel with Kevin for
for 10 plus years I would say I wanted
even before I knew him to travel with
Kevin and I finally got my chance and it
is represented in this segment we
travelled through who's Becca stand
together long story Kevin touches on a
lot of cool stuff and we had a blast
recording it in the back of a car as it
sped through the mountains so I hope you
enjoy it as much as I did
hi this is Kevin Kelly I'm sitting in
the back of a car crossing a mountain
pass about 2,000 meters in the attention
mountains in Uzbekistan and this
Pakistan is a Central Asian country
that's generally south of Russia north
of Afghanistan and next to all the other
stands like Kazakhstan Turkmenistan
Tajikistan sitting next to me as we
cross the mountains is Tim Ferriss the
legendary Explorer and explainer of
world-class performances and we're gonna
do a joint recording Tim's gonna tell us
about his favorite four cool tools we'll
find out what he's up to lately Tim why
don't you tell us about your first cool
tool okay the first cool tool ever
sitting in the back here we have bags
around us bottles of water a bunch of
different gadgets and objects piled in
my lab the first that I can talk about
is actually in my other piece of luggage
I don't have any checked luggage and it
is a jacket that I roll up and travel
with constantly it's from a brand called
now and a you I believe it's based in
Portland and you can think of it as a
blazer or a riding jacket and what what
makes it unique is a number of different
factors a you can roll it up and throw
it onto say a black t-shirt and you look
like you're ready for a business dinner
or a formal or semi-formal occasion so
it saves me the trouble of packing a lot
of collared shirts for instance there
are
shirts that don't wrinkle but they do
take up more space than say a black
t-shirt so this now and it could be I I
have a several different models at home
weather resistant of course was designed
in the Pacific Northwest you would
expect that which comes in handy so that
would be my first cool tool plenty of
pockets but there are lapels so you can
get away with murder you could wear it
in a light rain or you could wear it at
a nice dinner and it is an incredibly
flexible piece of clothing so one of the
hazards for me anyway if I try to roll
up a jacket I never quite get the
wrinkles out so no are your church you
can kind of hang in your hot shower and
it'll go dissipate how does this work in
terms of unwrinkle in it or do you does
it just magically unwrinkle so this
particular jacket has a number of
features I think that disguise wrinkles
and there's also just the material
science aspect the the fabric blends
that are used tend not to wrinkle number
one number two it has folds and pockets
and lapels that for whatever reason make
any wrinkles less noticeable cool and
then there's the color so if you want to
avoid problems with wrinkles generally
at least in my experience you want
darker clothing so that under light
you're not casting you're not having
shadows cast across or beneath the
wrinkles so this is a charcoal color
jacket it's kind of like your typical
suit jacket length or is it more like
outdoor jacket at the waist I would say
typical dinner jacket length so it's not
getting cut off doesn't show off any
midriff Lister you were looking for that
well you're out of luck yeah so you'd be
able to see your belt fit we're on
buttoned in the front right okay so
that's and it's very lightweight and
about tell the readers about how big it
compresses into if you were to roll it
up well and if you want to know how to
roll up a jacket like that well you
could actually go online and look at
say a judo uniform is folded and if you
roll it up well you are looking at let's
just say the the bottom three-quarters
meaning it'll cover the very bottom
fabric of a standard sized school
backpacks we're not thinking about a
hikers backpack so if I des tomato I
would say we're looking at I get it down
to about a roll that is ten inches in
length and about three to four inches in
diameter that's very impressive
I carry a lightweight down jacket that
can press this into something very small
but it it's certainly not as fancy or
you know suitable for a dinner jacket
like yours this and I mean a couple
other tips for folks and by I'm by no
means a hyper minimalist say Appalachian
Trail hike or anything like that but I
also have for instance a synthetic
because I don't want to lose the
insulating ability if it gets wet I have
a synthetic Down Vest that is also
stuffed into this backpack which I can
put on top of that sort of fancy looking
jacket in the case that I need more
warmth yeah that's that's brilliant
that's a brilliant hack so again that's
called the now jacket na you now know ok
and approximately what's it what's the
cost just give me a range that's a
really good question I bought it a long
time ago it's not it's not cheap but
then again if you're comparing it to any
type of dinner jacket or outdoor jacket
it's not horribly expensive I'd say it's
in the 150 to 350 range if I have to
guess okay good that's fantastic so what
else do you have in your backpack which
is stuffed here in the back of our car
right now I'm in my bag of tricks I have
a Logitech Bluetooth keyboard and
it's just to put this in perspective it
is about the slightly larger than say a
paperback book like a five by eight inch
trim paperback book it is narrow enough
that I will very often stick it into a
journal to protect it
meaning it's it's probably the width of
eight to ten paperback pages and it
holds a charge very very well so I use
this often times if I have any issue
with my laptop I can pair it to my
iPhone which is a larger sized iPhone
and balance the iPhone or lean it
against say a glass of iced tea and I
can get any type of writing done that I
need to get done also if I feel like
taking a day trip but not taking this
backpack which is one of my main pieces
of luggage and stuffed full of stuff
it's kind of heavy I can take the I can
take the keyboard and my iPhone and head
off to some coffee shop saying 10 15
minutes away without carrying all of my
gear with me so I'm going to try to
describe this a little bit further it's
very very thin and very lightweight it
feels like it's made of aluminum and it
has kind of a matte texture matte finish
on it and feels very velvety and it's
mostly charcoal color with white letters
and so this would serve as a keyboard
with a phone and in the keyboard itself
is pretty large in terms of your finger
spacing so there'd be no cramping that
is really cool yeah it's a great device
I've had this now for I would say two
years and I have never had a technical
fail so as a form of backup I find it to
be very cheap insurance because as you
can see in person this is lightweight
enough that I'm not gonna get scoliosis
for having this as additional piece of
gear I just stick it stick it into a
large format journal or even a magazine
and I can travel with it yeah that's
really cool and so it pairs up like food
bluetooth I imagine right that's right
right so you can pair it up to an iPad
if you wanted to as well as a phone if
Carrie definitely yeah so what's that
called again this is a Logitech
Bluetooth keyboard and we'll put the
exact yeah model in the show notes for
everybody and next up we have these all
kind of travel together I've very rarely
take these out of my backpack in this
case this is max earplugs silicone
earplugs which unlike foam earplugs are
not inserted into the ear canal and then
left to expand these are effectively
smeared over the ear opening and you
have in all caps do not insert just
cover ear opening these and I found
through swimmers in fact and they are
very waxy and almost look like candies
some type of caramel but they're white
colored and I find them to block sound
much more effectively than any type of
foam ear plug although there are some
good ones on the market to be sure to
use them just once or can they be reused
or recycled or they last a little bit
they new after they get grungy or what's
their use I definitely reuse these I
would say if I had to guesstimate I
would say four to five nights and then
they start to lose their adherence
because they get they get less tacky
over time the most important feature
benefit that I don't want to overlook is
that as someone who tends to rotate from
back to side so I sleep on my back and
on my side foam earplugs won't very
often hurt they'll get pushed into your
ear when you roll onto your side that is
not the case with these so so for side
sleepers this these aren't real a real
cool tool because it allows you to sleep
on your side while you have these
earplugs in definitely and even as
someone who kind of tosses and turns in
my case I don't tend to wake up on my
side but I'm constantly going onto my
side and foam earplugs often wake me up
cool and this is mostly just used for
sleeping or couldn't you use these do
you use these for other sorts of sound
abatement these these earplugs live in
each of my bags that I tend to travel
with so I have I have redundant caches
of earplugs one in this bag one in my
other bag and sometimes I'll even have
them a jacket it's mostly for sleeping
mostly for sleeping bird if you're
sitting on the airplane and you're
trying to read and just want to drown
out the sound then you can use it as
well for sure or you're swimming and you
want to avoid swimmers murmurs okay
right okay
okay so what's your fourth cool tool my
fourth cool tool and I might I might
might go over slightly here but my my
fourth and cool tool is a neck pillow
and I've tried many different neck
pillows yeah most of them are very
uninspiring and even less effective for
helping me sleep this and I'll do my
best here kaboo come I believe is the
pronunciation c a.b e a you and has
evolution pillow written on the side you
can see that it it compresses down very
nicely like a small like a small
cantaloupe or a large grapefruit and you
can certainly compress it more in the
actual bag that it comes and allows you
to wrap it up and then compress it down
to a smaller size and it is just very
nice in essence memory foam neck pillow
that also clips in the front what I
found is not only does it help me sleep
if I'm sitting upright but it's it's
also very very helpful for getting to
sleep when I'm laying prone whether it's
on an airplane or even in a hotel room
if the pillows are of dubious quality
and do you have to inflate this with
like pumping air in blowing air into it
or is it self expanding its self
expanding so it you can think of it
almost like a sponge-like material that
you can compress down and then when you
release it it inflates or I should say
rather expands
automatically it is it one of those
horseshoe shape items or is it it just a
little kind of wedge assist behind your
neck it is a horseshoe shaped if you
imagine a horseshoe being hung around
the back of your neck that is the shape
you can clip in the front and the design
is such that there's a ridge that
supports basically the occipital area
the back at the base of the skull so
it's very very ergonomic in that sense
it is it's the most comfortable neck
pillow that I have found and so I am
pretty light it's a little bulky but
it's pretty light yeah it's it's light
and as far as neck pillows go not very
bulky at all yeah but if you're gonna
have a neck pillow generally speaking in
my experience at least it's going to be
inflatable quite uncomfortable or you're
gonna end up with this type of
compromise and this is this is the best
I found right so it does we could pretty
easily disappear to add a pack oh yeah I
think it absolutely could and certainly
if you wanted you could lash this to the
outside of a pack I happen to have
enough space in my bag so I include it
but you could lash it or hang it on the
outside okay one one other cool tool
that you have which is more common here
than I would have expected but in
retrospect I shouldn't be surprised it
is very very hot here it can get very
very hot and the Sun is extremely
powerful to the extent that we visited a
solar furnace not long ago that can be
used to melt various objects at absurdly
high temperatures few thousand degrees
centigrade yeah exactly and you have
well our guide as our esteemed guide as
an umbrella smart move to create shade
wherever he wants it and you have an
umbrella but you made a modification to
your umbrella yeah so I just had an
ordinary cheap you know Chinese black
really compact umbrella that I carry in
my little camera bag all the time and I
spray painted the top of it silver so
that it reflects the light
and it makes it a little bit cooler on
the inside because just with the black
umbrella it tends to absorb that
infrared and re-radiate it back down on
your head I having a silver reflective
layer bounces at least you know 60% of
that packet to the sky it's a lot cooler
and there are versions of the silver
umbrella they're extremely lightweight
they're not as collapsible as the ones I
have but they're made for hiking there
they're there I think just call it the
silver dome if I'm not mistaken and they
are way only a few ounces and people out
west if you're climbing even into high
altitudes a lot of the long-distance
hikers now carry an umbrella portable
shade and they may walk along under the
shade shade follow them and it really
makes a huge difference when you're
backpacking because you can really work
up a sweat and the Hat doesn't allow
your head to cool off but the umbrella
does
[Music]
well there you have it folks
the Tim Ferriss Radio Hour with just a
handful the guests and experts I've
spoken with across more than 300 podcast
episodes and I myself am jonesing to
throw on the back pack some sandals and
hit the road which is exactly what I'm
doing tomorrow so the timing could not
be better and the Tim Ferriss Radio Hour
continues to be an experiment so please
let me know what you liked what you
didn't like how it can be improved how
my voice greats you haunts your dreams
what topics are themes you'd most like
me to explore in other words I'd love
any and all feedback so let me know on a
tweet Adam and that's usually the best
place to get my attention at tea Ferriss
TFE are Riss and let me know and until
next time as always thank you so much
for listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email for me every Friday that
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five below Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy
[Applause]
this episode is brought to you by red
dahlias new book principles if you're a
frequent listener of this podcast you
might recall that Rey was a guest on
this show his episode was extremely
popular and in that episode he shared
his thoughts on everything from how he
makes investment decisions to
cryptocurrency and beyond his story Ray
Dalio you should look him up for sure is
fascinating he started his investment
company some people would call it a
hedge fund there are different names
Bridgewater associates out of a
two-bedroom apartment at age 26 now it
has roughly 160 billion dollars in
assets under management over 42 years
he's built Bridgewater into what Fortune
considers the fifth most important
private company in the u.s. along the
way Dalio took tons and tons of notes on
what worked what didn't work and it was
refined over time for training purposes
with his employees managers and so on
Dalio became one of the 100 most
influential people in the world
according to time and one of the 100
wealthiest people in the world according
to Forbes in this book principles which
has a permanent spot on my bookshelf
also has blurbs and testimonials from
people like Bill Gates Michael Bloomberg
and many many more ray shares in those
pages the unconventional principles that
he's developed refined and used over the
past 40 years to create unique results
in both life business certainly and
investing and which any person
organization can adopt to help further
their goals these principles are what he
believes is the reason behind his many
many successes and principles the book
also offers a clear very straightforward
approach to decision making the dahlia
believes anyone can apply both in life
and work I highly highly recommend it it
will help you to become in almost any
context a clearer thinker so visit
principals dot-com for more details
amazing that he actually has that URL to
visit principals dot-com for more
details and to pick up a copy check it
out
this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn and their job recruitment
platform which offers a smarter system
for the hiring process
if you've ever hired anyone or attempted
to do it you know that finding the right
people can be extremely difficult and if
you don't have a direct referral from
someone you trust you're left to use job
boards that don't really offer any
real-world networking approach and what
I mean by that is in contrast LinkedIn
which is the world's largest
professional network has a built in
ecosystem that allows you to not only
search for employees but also interact
with them and their connections and
their former employers or colleagues in
a way that closely mimics real-life
communication more than 70% of the
workforce in the u.s. uses LinkedIn and
more than 22 million professionals view
and apply to LinkedIn every single week
unlike generic job boards LinkedIn
considers skills experienced in location
to match you with candidates making it
easier to find quality candidates and
maybe above all you can directly contact
a candidate's connections to get a good
sense of if they are a good fit for your
business
so visit linkedin.com forward slash Tim
and receive a $50 credit towards your
first job post that's linkedin.com
forward slash tim TI m for $50 off
you